you have about 20,000 genes in your DNA
they encode the molecules that make up
your body from the keratin in your
toenails to the collagen at the tip of
your nose to the dopamine surging around
inside your brain other species have
genes of their own a spider has genes
for spider silk an oak tree has genes
for chlorophyll which turns sunlight
into wood so where did all those genes
come from it depends on the gene
scientists suspect that life started on
earth about 4 billion years ago the
early life-forms were primitive microbes
with a basic set of genes for the basic
tasks required to stay alive they passed
down those basic genes to their
offspring through billions of
generations some of them still do the
same jobs in our cells today like
copying DNA but none of those microbes
had genes for spider silk or dopamine
there are a lot more genes on earth
today than there were back then it turns
out that a lot of those extra genes were
born from mistakes each time a cell
divides it makes new copies of its DNA
sometimes it accidentally copies the
same stretch of DNA twice in the process
it may make an extra copy of one of its
genes at first the extra gene works the
same as the original one but over the
generations it may pick up new mutations
those mutations may change how the new
gene works and that new gene may
duplicate again a surprising number of
our mutated genes emerged more recently
many in just the past few million years
the youngest evolved after our own
species broke off from our cousins the
Apes while it may take over a million
years for a single gene to give rise to
a whole family of genes scientists are
finding that once the new genes evolve
they can quickly take on essential
functions for example we have hundreds
of genes for the proteins in our noses
that grab odor molecules the mutations
let them grab different molecules giving
us the power to perceive trillions of
different smells
sometimes mutations have a bigger effect
on new copies of
they may cause a gene to make its
protein in a different organ or at a
different time of life or the protein
may start doing a different job
altogether in snakes for example there's
a gene that makes a protein for killing
bacteria long ago the gene duplicated
and the new copy mutated that mutation
changed the signal in the gene about
where it should make its protein instead
of becoming active in the snakes
pancreas it started making this bacteria
killing protein in the snakes mouth so
when the snake bit its prey this enzyme
got into the animals wound and when this
protein proved to have a harmful effect
and helped the snake catch more prey it
became favored so now what was a gene in
the pancreas makes a venom in the mouth
that kills the snake's prey and there
are even more incredible ways to make a
new gene the DNA of animals and plants
and other species contain huge stretches
without any protein coding genes as far
as scientists can tell it's mostly
random sequences of genetic gibberish
that serve no function these stretches
of DNA sometimes mutate just like genes
do sometimes those mutations turn the
DNA into a place where a cell can start
reading it suddenly the cell is making a
new protein at first the protein may be
useless or even harmful but more
mutations can change the shape of the
protein the protein may start doing
something useful something that makes an
organism healthier stronger better able
to reproduce scientists have found these
new genes at work in many parts of
animal bodies so our 20,000 genes have
many origins from the origin of life to
new genes still coming into existence
from scratch as long as life is here on
earth it will be making new genes
you